hello everyone and welcome to Game five
of the 1972 World Championship match
between Boris Vasilyev it's basking in
the Robert James Fisher before we dive
in the Game five we do have to mention a
couple of things about Game four and
some what about Game three now as
several subscribers have mentioned in
the comments and also via email there
aside from a lot of books already
existing I'm using the one by said to
certain legal issue also there is one
about by Larry Evans I also have one by
Dmitri Bill it's about this whole
encounter - by Dimitri build so that is
one about fishing one about Spassky
there is also a book by spassky's a
second a Nikolai Kroger's about this
match which is in Russian luckily there
is there are short bits about from this
book about this encounter by Nicola
Nicola Nikolai crow goose in English a
certain user translated it from Russian
to English and uploaded it to chess calm
so I will put the entire diary there
will be a link in the description below
so feel free to check it out and also
there is a very nice interview with
Anatoly Karpov
about Fischer and amongst other things
about the dis match also there will be a
link in the description below to chess
base saying that it's very interesting
how in Game three
although Spassky lost through that game
Fischer really played an excellent game
there was a there was one move that b3
moved that possibly could have used from
his home preparation to you know get out
of everything but as you see the quote
above the board as Karpov mentions in
his interview about Boris Spassky that
he was lazy and he didn't really work
all that much on his chest
so when his seconds were showing him
what to do in this situation what to do
in this situation because they really
have prepared for it I mean FF angular
is one of the greatest home preparation
artists of that time but most of the
time is a Spassky didn't really either
trust them or he didn't want to memorize
the entire variation he was just I'm
just gonna find it over the board if
that position ever arises over the board
so there being said
Geller was very disappointed and even
angry at Spassky for losing Game three
not because he lost everyone can lose
the game but but because he had a move
that could get him out of trouble and
there was a move they found in home
preparation but Geller was like why you
do this pass key and it's very
interesting how Geller didn't really
mind all that much that as Pascal lost
Game three but he was a even more
unimpressed that's possibly missed that
rook to DA to move in Game four if you
remember from my previous video if you
don't I'll put a link to it in the
description below to check it out in
that one instance Spassky played rope to
h8 instead of first playing group to d8
and then bringing it back to h8 just so
there would be a pawn and c3 and the
Fisher couldn't use it to exchange
Queens with Spassky and in the interview
Karpov also mentions that before their
trip to Reykjavik as you know as passkey
second tsar nicolai crow goose effing
Geller and leave on a Estonia
international master all of them went to
Reykjavik but before they had a training
camp it was some 60 kilometers from
Moscow and not only the three of them
but also in it Anatoly Karpov was part a
part of this training camp so it Chess
Federation sent in there to you know
just gain experience and see how you
prepare for a match and perhaps you you
know especially could you seem to have
some training sessions and Karpov
mentions that Spassky did wanted to have
a training session with him but they
only played one game Karpov was better
in that game but at one point as Karpov
says in the interview he made a stupid
mistake and then Spassky won the game
and Spassky was no longer internet
interested in having a training session
with Karpov perhaps he didn't like how
the twenty-year-old Karpov her hadn't
had a better position right out of the
opening so that being said
Karpov also mentions that Spassky was
traveling a lot the Moscow and then back
to the training camp to Moscow back to
the training camp some 60 kilometers
every day and that he didn't really
spend all that much time in the training
camp during his preparations
for the match in Reykjavik carpel
mentions that Spassky would only just
come visit in the evenings and as you
can see in the court above the board
they would show Spassky okay this could
happen this could happen this could
happen and Spassky was like if it
happens I'll just find it over the board
he liked it like I said he wasn't really
all that much into memorizing lines and
this is why Geller was so angry about
game four where Spassky should have
taken a winner what did the black pieces
and now continue with an even greater
lead because if you look at how things
went our first game wasn't really a
victory by Spassky was really a loss by
first second game fishel forfeited
without even showing up game 3 Fischer
won ok was a brilliancy but Spassky had
a refutation in home preparation in game
4 I should have been a victory for
Spassky as it was already won during
home preparation Karpov says that carpet
was watching this game he was not in
Reykjavik but rather he was preparing
for the Chess Olympiad with Petrosyan
Korchnoi a mechanical talent Paul
Karason they were analyzing it and they
were like oh I've seen this
Spassky has this already from home
preparation and then Spassky doesn't
play it I was very strange but okay this
is now game 5 and now like we said a
game for was a drawled or should have
been a victory for Spassky so so far as
possible II didn't do all that much
game 1 yes he won by Fischer capturing
on H 2 game 2 he won by forfeit a game 3
he lost in Game four he should have won
so and not really going too well for
Spassky and here there is a very
interesting part from legal his book
that I really just want to read it -
because it's about Fischer making even
more demands towards the Icelandic Chess
Federation so it's just a small bit from
the book before the fifth game with
Spassky the rumor spread that Fischer
had put 14 new demands to the Icelandic
Chess Federation he wanted to change
rooms he asked to be allowed to sign
bills whenever he want he wanted more
pocket money than his allowance of ten
dollars a day and
new Mercedes car had the one he was
given to was two years old the option to
change the playing room a larger supply
of American newspapers and magazines
personal control of filming he's on his
own often Don switch a chessboard with
squares 1/8 of an inch smaller the use
of an indoor tennis court and the
exclusive use of the hotel swimming pool
and so on so of course the Icelandic
Chess Federation didn't want to really
comment on this so no one was really
sure how much of this was true and how
much of it was exaggerated because at
this point pretty much anything you've
heard about Fischer was was either
exaggerated or you know blown out of
proportion
but we're gonna get back to this after
the game because it's very interesting
and I was also very impressed if any of
you by any chance have this book by
sweaters or Glee go teach in English
here he also there we have it let me
just check aha
this is how Fischer oriented himself so
excellently so I was very impressed that
the Glivec uses excellently in the book
so ok this is Game five let's see what
happens
sorry about the longer intro but you
know you can never have too much vast
knowledge about anything and especially
about the 1972 World Chess Championship
match so ok before the game
Spassky seconds asked Spassky it does he
perhaps won't arrest today because both
players were allowed a couple of rest
days and thus possibly said no I don't
want to rest I want to fight I have two
white pieces and I really want to play
this game you know I really wanted to be
a fighting game and no one could really
say anything just Pascal because there
were instances you know before where
Spassky was down in a match he was a you
know down in a tournament and then he
would recollect himself and just start
winning games so who was anyone to tell
Spassky anything
Spassky plays d4 we have Knight to f6 c4
e6 Knight to c3 here Spassky invites
Fischer to go straight into the
nimzo-indian defense and Fischer doesn't
hesitate we have Bishop to be for the
nimzo-indian Indian
fences on the board and here Spassky
allows Fischer to go for any variation
of the names of Indian because Spassky
is very much interested in a fight he
really wants to win a game against
Fischer especially with the white pieces
and he wants Fischer to play any line he
wants Knight to f3 by Spassky as poss he
hesitates with III although it was the
most favorable idea at the moment but he
wants to keep his options of developing
the Bishop to g5 c5 now Fischer invites
Spassky to play III thus eliminating
this option of developing the Bishop to
g5 we have III ninth to c6 Bishop to d3
simply developing captures captures we
have d6 and now II four we have E 5 by
Fischer and now d5 Spassky closes the
center and 97 the knight will be very
useful in protecting the Kings side
Knight to h4 by Spassky a very nice idea
this Knight at one point is coming to a5
so Fischer if he castles then the knight
will be very useful on f5 and if Fischer
wants to eliminate it you will have to
give up his light square Bishop here
Fischer plays h6 a very nice idea
Fischer is preparing g5 he wants to
prevent Spassky from at some point
pushing f4 and here also we have a
moment this is only move 11 and he
responds 25 minutes and move 11 and
after those 25 minutes he pushes f4 and
Fischer without much consideration to
the position even those possibly spend
so much time on this move plays Knight
to g6 and Knight to g6 is definitely the
best idea simply attacking that f4 pawn
and also challenging the knight on h4
and now that this night is done g6
Knight to f5 no longer really works here
Fischer can simply capture on f4 Knight
captures we have night cap person g7 but
this is not not so important now King to
a fate attacking the knight but sure
captures pawn captures and now Knight
moves back Bishop captures pawn captures
and Queen to e7 and after Queen to e2
characters captures rook to g8
Fisher's utter rook is coming to e8 and
now you can see that spark is a light
square Bishop isn't really all that
impressive
it's caged between
his own points and the Fisher's night
will be a very very impressive piece
once he maneuvers at to e5
so after Knight to g6 as possibly has to
capture the knight Knight captures we
have F captures on g6 and now F captures
on e5 not really an important move at
some point this capture what happened so
Spassky does it now D captures only five
and now Bishop to e3 and here by playing
Bishop to e3 first or simply plays b6
and now you can see that Spassky doesn't
really have all that much to push for a
win here with the white pieces now
Fischer is very solid both on the King
set on the Queen side we have castles by
Spassky castles by Fischer and the now a
four spot sketcher is trying to break
through and in any way he can simply a5
Fischer blocks completely blocks off the
Queen side and now he says that there's
nothing you can do yes you do have the
bishop repair but you're better prepare
isn't really all that impressive my
light square bishop is on the other hand
very impressive and my knight it's very
impressive and perhaps will do great
things in the future so k-rock the b1 a
very useful move fresh replace Bishop to
d7 simply stating that the a4 pawn
Spassky left isolated here is is a very
weak bone and Spassky will have to use
pieces to defend it
rope to be - Spassky not prepares to
bring the other rook over to the F file
double ropes and the a file and perhaps
try something there we have looked to be
eight and here comes rugby - f2 as
planned
here we have Queen to e7 by Fischer you
have to be careful not bow hunter with
Queen to c7 because you do have to keep
an eye on the h6 bone for example Bishop
captures
would be very uncomfortable for black
recaptures and now you can simply
capture on f6 as the pawn is no longer
guarding the knight on f6
here white would simply snatch her pawn
and keep a better position so Queen 2 is
7 by Fischer we have a bishop to c2 now
improving the the position also bringing
another defender of the e4 pawn and also
creating some room for the Queen on d3
and here Fischer can simplify
immediately and if he wants he can play
Knight to g4 and this would be the at
least a draw for him for example capture
captors captures captures who simply
exchange all the looks now Queen to e2
captures captures and now after g5 the
queen is coming to f4 and it's I mean
it's it's a better position for black
but a white cannot win this game there's
no way but Fischer is isn't really
interested in just drawing the game yet
he wants something more so first he
pushes g5 and ok we have a bishop to d2
Spassky is planning this maneuver Bishop
to d2 to e1 and at some point he would
very much enjoy if this bishop could
come to g3 this would be very nice maybe
he could create some threats against the
d5 pawn 28 and the now comes Bishop to
e1 Queen to g6 and now comes Queen to d3
a very nice move the queen is now adding
further protection to d4 pawn also
Spassky is now even considering Queen to
g3 Knight to h5 at some point the rooks
are getting exchanged so why not to do
it now and the decide is now definitely
coming to f4 we have rook captures on f8
rook captures rook captures and King
captures the rooks are now off the board
and here we have Bishop to d1 a very
nice move attacking the knight and also
making the room for Queen to come to b1
- perhaps force Fischer's Queen - stay
on the 6th rank as she will have to keep
an eye on the b6 pawn further simply
plays Knight to f4 and once again as
possibly found himself in time trouble
and here on move 27 he makes a critical
mistake here he should have continued
with Queen to be one although Fischer
still still keeps a better position but
instead he played the Queen to c2 for
some reason probably decided to keep his
queen with a better defense of the King
side but this move loses immediately so
feel free to pause the video here and
play the move that Fischer played to win
this game 5 of this historic match I'll
give it a couple of seconds prove to the
side as usual for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
here at first simply played Queen Bishop
captures on a4
and when Spassky saw this he simply
resigned the game why did he resign
well obviously can you capture the
bishop it seems like the bishop is
unguarded if you capture the bishop
Queen captures on e4 and there is no
defense either Queen captures anyone
will be checkmate or Queen captures and
g2 will be checkmate
you can't stop both you can prolong the
game for a bit by running away with the
king
but still it's checkmate in four there
is no way out of it simply United III
check King moves Queen to h4 check King
moves Queen to f4 check King moves and
now nice to see one a beautiful night
checkmate and on the other hand after
Bishop to a4 if you don't capture the
bishop if you simply move the Queen
although there really aren't all that
many squares for the Queen
simply bushel capture some d1 Queen
captures and now Queen captures on e4
again threatening checkmate you have to
prevent this let's say Queen to d2 and
now simply nice capture son g2 White is
down so much material Queen captures and
now Queen captures on d1 with Czech
Queen has to block on the move you
exchanged Queens and bring up three
points it would be a very easy win for
Fischer so yeah such a move hidden in
the position Spassky
I mean Spassky of course could have
drawn this game at it many times during
the game but as he was looking for ways
to win you know a simple threat like a
present a four can often sneak a sneak
up on you so that's game five I do hope
you enjoyed it and remember when we said
in the beginning we were reading parts
from Glico ridges book about Fischer's
demands towards the Icelandic chess
federation now it's hard to say how many
of them were true how many of them were
exaggerations but a Fischer did
celebrate after this game the hotel
swimming pulled it closed at 10:00 p.m.
and Fischer spent two hours alone in the
swimming pool s celebration for winning
Game five against Boris Spassky so
that's the game I I do hope you enjoyed
it i really enjoyed preparing it as I
really enjoyed preparing all of these
games for you I would like to thank
Kenneth we're in a Julian Bosch Martin
Wilbur Chris Picard and Roberts have a
chance for a contribution to
my channel and many more of you as
yesterday's 16 people contributed to my
channel but I only have room for 5
people per video but don't worry all of
you will have your rightful place in my
chest videos so once again I really hope
you enjoyed it to check out the links
you know the interview with carp of the
short bits from the diary by nikolai cro
goose and a lot of other useful links
there will be a link to game 4 if you've
missed it by any chance as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
with the legendary game 6 or if you have
any good suggestions from the bottom
which s olympiad feel free to hashtag
suggestion me thank you all and I'll see
you soon